EVERYONE DID AN OOPSIE
Good evening everyone I'm
MARY HAM
*intro plays*
Ham News
My name is Mary Ham and I like ham
Our first story comes from Gloria Borger
Gloria Borger has passed away
Now I'm not supposed to give my opinion
but this is so sad
Poppy Gloria was found dead
in her apartment
We don't know yet who's responsible
but we do know that I was the last person
seen with Poppy Gloria alive
Let's have a moment of silence for Poppy Gloria
NEXT *clap* NEWS *clap* *music plays*
Our next story follows YouTube
YouTube did an oopsie
wHAAT
NO WAY THAT CAN BE RIGHT
*chuckles*
What did YouTube do this time?
They gave a shout-out to SSSniperWolf
okay
not that big of a deal
"This is the future!" SniperWolf is here
to share some of the craziest vending machines all around the world
PewDiePie
had this to say:
Oh, I didn't show up 'cause I...
OH IN YOUTUBE'S MAIN?
Their main? Whaat?
*unintelligible*
Some people were upset about this,
saying that this channel plagiarizes clickbait articles
like Buzzfeed every day without citing a source
Promote channels that do research
and write their own material, please
Now to be fair, this isn't on SSSniperWolf
This is more on YouTube
*laughs*
I mean I can't really fault anyone
for making low quality content
*laughs*
EXCEPT HAM NEWS
I do research goddammit
and I'm not upset at SniperWolf, okay
I don't even care that she got to meet
Keanu Reeves
IT DOESN'T REALLY BOTHER ME AT ALL
I HAVEN'T MEET KEANU REEVES SO WHY CAN'T I
and it doesn't even bother me,
that she's been on the trending page
TWO DAYS IN A ROW
AHURG AUEH
I don't even have any opinions
so it would be literally impossible for me to care
NEXT NEWS
We have an update on the Tfue vs FaZe drama
Now this is höttest drama that has ever drop-
deh
Tfue is suing FaZe Clan
OHMYGOD
*boom*
honestly why does anyone care?
*laughs*
Now Tfue said:
Uuh release the contract
pls
But FaZe Clan, please release the contract
and then Faze Clan be like
Oh, we ARE releasing the contract
and then FaZe Clan be like
...okay we not gonna actually release the contract
we're just gonna make a video
"Multiple different versions of contracts"
WOW
Careful there, buddy
you're showing a bit too information
wow
thanks for releasing the contract
now we can go through ALL of it
This is great, thank you
*laughs*
Careful not to show TOO MUCH
Just put the contract out there
they're crazy
...2018
OHMYGOD THERE'S sO mUCH INFORMATION
"Like we didn't know if he wanted more monthly salary,
we sent him a deal that was gonna pay him
seven figures a year"
Why do they always do that?
They always say seven figures
it's one million
Whenever someone says seven figures,
that means a million
it doesn't mean anything else
SEVEN FIGURE- Oh, a million
So they addressed the allegations
that FaZe is taking money out of their code Tfue stuff
which apparently is a LOT of money
into that Fortnite purchase code thingbajigga
"We've seen a little miscommunication
on terms of community understanding about in-game items
and what that might mean and what that applied to"
"Let us be very on the record right now,
that has nothing to do with supporting creator codes"
Tfue was signed in April of 2018,
while Epic announced Support-A-Creator in October of 2018
So, they're basically saying:
it was IMPOSSIBLE for us to take money out of his
'cause you know they would've had it in their deal
If this contract happened after they announced this
"Support-A-Creator" program
you know, you know damn well they would put something in that
but they're saying that they wouldn't do that
I-i-i kind doubt on that
"When it became clear to us that his-"
I've never seen more private texts,
in my entire life than these past three weeks
Everyone is just all:
Private text? I'll put that in a video
"When it became clear to us that his pure intention was
really just to leave,
that's very difficult"
So they addressed the criticism that Faze's been getting
because Tfue obviously wants out of this contract
Why can't you just let them?
...him
and they say this:
"Oh, why didn't you just let him out?"
because our fans have invested their time, and their effort,
and their care, and their love,
into the relationship that we created with Tfue too"
the f*ck kind of argument is that?
it's for the fans, guys
they're just looking out the fans
So, they wanna preserve this relationship that they have
between the fans and Faze Clan
..and Tfue
but Tfue clearly wants nothing to do with Faze Clan
So what kind of relationship are you preserving there?
Am I, am I caveman dummy-dumb?
I don't get it, what's the argument?